[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the observer's
chief lead writer sonia soder and the
daily telegraph's chief of political
correspondent christopher hope who we
are hoping excuse the pun uh who will
join us shortly he's having um well
wi-fi issues or something like that
anyway we'll find out soon uh to the
front pages then let us start with the
eye which declares the tories put the pm
on notice commenting on the ongoing
ferrari around parties boris johnson's
remarks tusakistama about jimmy savile
and britain's role in the situation in
ukraine
the guardian says the pm went to another
prosecco fueled leaving do for an aid at
number 10.
the times is leading with energy bill
rebates to help against rising costs
the metro reports on an investigation
which discovered that racist
misogynistic and homophobic whatsapp
messages were sent by officers working
at a police station in central london
the telegraph hears that hormone
replacement therapy will soon be sold
over the counter
while the ft's international edition
looks at the prospect of interest rate
rises from the european central bank
and the star says we can breathe a sigh
of relief over a tea room classic
there we are well a reminder that by
scanning the qr code that you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out those front pages and the ones
coming in soon of tomorrow's newspapers
while you watch us so let's bring in
sonia soda
on her own on none of them
hey and crystal at home you're there
what marvelous news uh we were hoping
obviously that you would be there anyway
let's go straight to the eye shall we uh
both of you um and uh you know this is
like a sort of a condition check of
where the pm pm is right now isn't it
sonia
absolutely so the eye does what it does
so well um on many occasions which is
bring the day's political stories
together
and sort of give us an overall summary
of what's going on so it makes reference
to developments in
the partygate scandal which a couple of
the other papers have got stories
leading on new revelations about new
parties
concerns from very senior mps about
the impact that johnson's domestic
political crisis is having on his
ability to represent britain on a world
stage an absolutely critical moment for
world affairs um so you know that's the
the russia ukraine crisis
and then
essentially the rumblings are going on
uh politically
we've seen uh that the su grey report
that came out it was uh very much an
interim report without
concrete findings it didn't have
concrete revelations about what happened
at the downing street parties although
it had some very tough words
about cultures in downing street but
that has somewhat diffused i think at
the momentum
around uh sort of back bench efforts to
to get boris johnson out of downing
street immediately
but these conversations are rumbling on
uh behind the scenes and and the eye
alludes to them as well yes it was
general lord richard dannett wasn't it
he'd said that uh the the swirling
partygate rumors were like a time bomb
and that uh you know in in the world of
foreign affairs people would realize
that but let's go to the guardian shall
we christopher um this is one of those
allegations that was listed in sue
grey's report that we did not know about
the guardian suggesting they found out
more
that's right there's allegations here in
both the guardian and the telegraph
tonight about boris johnson going to
that party the winner takes it all party
anna
on the night that uh dominic cummings
left
number 10 he was going to say wasn't he
yeah those are two different uh things
aren't they uh one of them was november
the 13th which was the uh
winner takes it all party the abba
singing one in the flat
and the other one that we were talking
about in the guardian uh is one actually
on the 14th of january uh suggesting it
was the departure of two number 10
private secretaries and the guardian
saying that boris johnson did attend uh
what they call a prosecco field leaving
do for a number ten aid during that now
people just go on to say it was only for
five minutes but does that make any
difference
i don't think so i mean gosh it's just
so hard to keep track of all these
different parties and the soundtracks
there were and what was being drunk but
i think it was inevitable that see
gray's report coming out and listing the
events that she was investigating
that would lead to leaks about some of
the ones that we don't know about so as
you said anna there are some on that
list that we don't know about and i
think you know we have to distinguish
the sort of steady drip now about
revelations from the political damage
that this is doing to boris johnson and
it is i guess quite easy to sort of be a
bit complacent oh another party that he
went to we already knew about kind of
you know however many it was i've
actually lost track myself um but i
think if we take a step back and look at
the big picture i think this drip is
going to continue um but i think the
damage there's an irreverent irrevocable
damage that's been done to the
relationship between boris johnson and
voters and we've seen that in the
opinion opinion polls if there's one
thing the public really don't like when
it comes to politicians it's political
hypocrisy we saw that with the expenses
scandal we've seen it with this and so
it isn't really necessarily the detail
about parties here it's the fact that
boris johnson
didn't see fit allegedly to abide by the
rules that he set for everyone else and
that many many voters and citizens
complied with at huge personal costs to
themselves you know missing funerals
missing saying goodbye to loved ones let
alone you know going to a work leaving
day so um i i think you know we are
going to continue to hear more and and
but i think the damage has already been
done to be honest well i mean the date
of some of these is really important
isn't it you know the one that really
upset a lot of people was the the the
parties uh the alleged parties before
prince philip's funeral and this one you
know just over a week after
the second national lockdown and within
the same week you know um
1820 people dead in one day you know at
that time you know the most people dead
it's just the context of this isn't it i
suppose you know it's easy to sort of
brush over them but
you know nobody's ever been able to tell
us how and why anybody thought this was
okay christopher
exactly i think um this idea that andrew
mitchell talked about about this idea of
of the lifeblood of the of the
government leeching away into the sand
um we want to see more from boris
johnson and we can't see it it's almost
a sorry not sorry prime minister and as
soon as he starts to step up i mean
we're waiting to see the shake-up so far
the response to the sugar report has
been a new government department in
number 10 downing street and that's
about it it's not enough
but his friends in the tory party tell
me you know unless he starts listening
and recognizing the problem then nothing
will change and we'll have this you know
repeated i understand that more letters
are going in tomorrow about boris
johnson um i know who they are that they
they won't confirm to me they're going
i'm pretty sure they are going in and
and these guys these are kind of unknown
if you want to see their names how many
roughly do you think
as many as as many as three tomorrow
going in that'll take it to
unknown numbers going towards 12 or 13.
these are not well known people they are
backwoodsman tory mps who have had
enough um and there's a lot of those
really and the problem for the pm might
be the number might stumble over the 54
required and inadvertently trigger this
no confidence vote in the
pm um obviously boris johnson said sorry
uh in parliament did he not on monday
but then he came out fighting uh you
know accusing kia stammer of a tissue of
nonsense and then raising this jimmy
savile accusation which has been widely
condemned still continues in the papers
there's the metro several victims fury
um and has prompted quite a backlash
this did not go down well even on the
tory back benches it seems uh sonia
well it's just dreadful really because
it's untrue
um whether or not to prosecute jimmy
savile was not a decision that was taken
by kierstarma when he was heading up the
crown prosecution service
but boris johnson said that it was in
parliament and i think you know i think
the first thing to say is actually some
of the most upsetting thing one of the
most upsetting things about this story
is what jimmy savile's victims have said
about it and they've come out and said
how distressing it is for them to feel
like their abuse is being used as a
political football being used by the
prime minister of the country to
effectively try and distract from the
political crisis that he finds himself
mired in i think it's completely
irresponsible actually and reprehensible
and um you know i i think their words
say it best really if you listen to some
of what they've been saying today it's
just
not okay for child sex abuse to be
deployed as a political football by our
prime minister well what's your feeling
about this christopher because it was
from the donald trump playbook wasn't it
to deliberately say
known untruths as truths we're better
than that in this country aren't we
he was playing the man not the ball it
was very clunky watching it from the
press gallery in the house of commons i
mean what happened was when kiestama was
in charge of the cps he did a review
into all of this stuff he had no actual
say over charge or not charging a saddle
he did issue a statement in 2013
apologizing for failings on behalf of
the cps for all prosecutors not him he
had no say over the actual prosecution
of savile personally and that's where
the where it's all it's so difficult i
think for johnson because he's late he's
saying that uh starmer in the commons
was involved he wasn't um it felt clunky
at the time we all looked each other
thinking what on earth does he talk
about why is savile involved in this
conversation about partygate and i'm not
surprised we're seeing here on metro
page five that the victims of savile are
really upset because it wasn't really
anything to do with partygate it
certainly wasn't i mean it's always
absurd and and
offensive to to do that i think
uh and so uh to ukraine he went today as
we saw uh the telegraph uh reporting on
its front page and no doubt plenty of
pages inside too
um that johnson has sent a stark message
to krem to the kremlin uh the western
sanctions will hit moscow as soon as the
first russian toe cap crosses into
ukraine you know typical use of boris
johnson language there i suppose um are
they getting anywhere do you think are
they making any headway
i think it's very difficult to know and
i genuinely think this is a sort of
situation actually where it's quite
difficult to know exactly what will
deter president putin from doing what he
wants to do
and i think you know
sort of britain and allies have really
stepped up in terms of sending
reinforcements to countries
neighboring ukraine to ukraine itself
but it is one of these sort of um
like situations where i think you're on
the brink of a conflict and it's quite
hard to know exactly what action to take
with a player like president putin the
thing i will say though you know it
comes back to sort of johnson being
quite distracted by what's going on at
home that really does undermine i think
britain on the world stage uh we had the
prime minister having to move his call
with the kremlin from monday to
wednesday
tomorrow uh basically because
he was too busy um going to parliament
to talk about the partygate scandal and
the sugray report so i i do think he is
um distracted and that's obviously not
good and
you know we saw the um the president of
the us uh his press secretary today sort
of crack a joke when she was asked about
uh about about whether what what the
president might make of what's going on
in the uk and she said well you know the
president has never been accosted by a
cake and obviously that's that's quite a
humorous way of dealing with that but i
do think it's quite revealing actually
of um how the rest of the world is is
looking on as the uk just becomes
absolutely mired in this um to the
guardian now christopher uh it's it's
leveling up big day isn't it what does
that mean in this context
well we'll find out tomorrow anna when
the leveling up for white papers
published by michael go if he of course
is the leveling up secretary it's an
idea leveling up which you might argue
is what all governments should do lift
opportunity for all um an idea which
boris johnson came out with in about
november 2019 and it taken until now to
find out what it is but a lot of tories
are hoping that this will define what
johnsonism is finally that idea of what
does boris johnson stand for because the
mandate in 2019 was for boris johnson
personally
less so the tory party of him personally
but the problem with a lot of politics
is no one knows what he believes or
stands for this might show us tomorrow
um the the front page the telegraph is
saying there that go will um unveil
leveling up pledges all that will become
law
to back to that idea that um you know
forget me saying as a minister it'll be
law therefore it will stay in statute
for labor to follow i doubt labour will
argue with much of this when lisa nanny
stands up to take on michael gove
tomorrow at the dispatch box um the hope
is it'll be something so far i've been
pretty unimpressed by the leaks and the
briefings so far so the hope is this can
deliver something for what the choice
promised in 2019. yeah the telegraph
saying that a dozen pledges to level up
britain are to be enshrined in law to
try to set the government's agenda for
the rest of the decade
mr gove the leveling up secretary
compared the uk to a jet firing on only
one engine and pledged to return
government focus to overlooked and
undervalued communities his policy
document runs to about 350 pages and is
the culmination of months of work by him
and his leveling up task force led by
andy holden former chief economist at
the bank of england 350 pages they
clearly know what it means then sonia
well possibly but i think the criticism
of this agenda is that first of all it
involves a lot of stuff that the
government's already announced a lot of
money that the government's already
announced
um we're being told about this new
approach which is legislating for
targets to close the gap
legislating doesn't really target really
doesn't make much difference unless
you've got substantive policies in place
and the real problem is is that actually
if you look at the government's policy
in the round it tugs against leveling up
so when you look for example at the tax
credit cuts that we've seen over the
last decade by conservative chancellors
some low paid parents have lost
thousands of pounds a year as a result
of that
when we look at cuts to public services
um particularly services for uh
vulnerable children for older people for
example
cuts to government grants to local
authorities have really hit the least
affluent areas of the country the most
and then you've got the effects of
brexit and um all the economic
predictions suggest that brexit and the
the costs uh to trade that happen as a
result of us leaving the european union
in quite an abrupt way
um will make themselves felt on on the
least affluent areas of the country so
the government's got a massive problem
which is that what a lot of the
government has been doing has been
tugging against leveling up and now it's
coming up with a leveling up agenda with
a lot of reheated cash which isn't
really going to do very much to counter
act
apologies we're running out of time i do
apologize um it does talk about 4g
coverage and uh and a nationwide
gigabyte capable broadband which would
help you christopher as well with your
wi-fi issues as well i'll see you soon
sonia christopher thank you both very
much indeed let's uh